[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه
[موسيقى]
برعايه الامميه صالح والمشري يلتقيان في
القاهره للتوافق حول الانتخابات الليبيه
النواب الامريكيون يفشلون مجددا في انتخاب
رئيس المجلسهم بعد ست جولات اقتراع
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا البدايه من ايران حيث
ذكر التقارير ايرانيه ان قائد الشرطه
العميد حسين عشري تم اقالته بامر
لكن لم يتم اصدار اعلان الرسمي يؤكد ذلك
حتى الان واضافت التقارير ان خامئي وبخل
عميد عشري الذي تولى منصبه في عام 2015
بسبب فشريه في التعامل مع احتجاجات
الشعبيه المستمره منذ اشهر وبحسب التقرير
ايضا الى حاله ارتباك داخل النظام
الايراني
لكنه بقيه بل ابقى على عشتري في بسطه منذ
عام 2015
شخصا تحت التعذيب في المعتقلات الاعترافات
ومنعهم ايضا من تلقي العلاج بعد اصابتهم
برصاصه اللجنه ايضا بان النحو واثني عشر
شخصا قتلوا وفي مريب بعضنا اكثر من 500
قتيل في الاحتجاجات الايرانيه خلال الاشهر
اربعه الماضيه في السجون الايرانيه
مشاهدينا ايضا تواصل 15 سجينه سياسيه
ايرانيه اضرابهن عن الطعام اليوم الثالث
على التوالي فيما اعلن محمد مهدي كرمي
المتطاير الايراني المحكوم عليه بالاعدام
عن دخوله في اضراب عن الطعام احتجاجا على
تايد حكم اعدام ومع زياده الضغوط على
المحتاجين السجناء في ايران بدات موجه
واسعه من الاضرابات عن الطعام في السجون
وورد التقارير تفيده بتعرض لصحه السجناء
للخطر ودخل اضراب كل من السجينات
السياسيات في ايران ارمستا عباسي والهام
مدرسيه وحميده وفاطمه حرب
ميراز احمد وسجينات الاخريات عن الطعام
يومه الثالث على التوالي كما اعلنت اربع
عشره معتقله في سجن اضربهن عن الطعام
باسباب مختلفه منها اوضع السجن
وعدم قبولي محامي وتحديد كفاله
اظهرت ايضا مشاهدينا صور متداوله تمزيقه
صوره قائد فريق القدس السابق في الحرس
الثوري الايراني قاسم السليماني في مدينه
في محافظه الفارس جنوبيه ايران وذلك بعد
يوم على الذكر الثالثه لمقتل سليمان
[تصفيق]
سعود اذا قائد الشرطه حسين عشري ماذا يعرف
عنه اسباب اقالته اذا ما صحته وتاكدت هذه
التقارير
تحياتي لك والمشاهد الكرام
طبعا اشتري كان من ابراج
قاده الشرطه الذين عينهم المرشد الاعلى في
هذا الموسم
نحن نعرف بانه اييه قائد الشرطه وقائد
كافه فروع القوات المسلحه الايرانيه من
الحرس الثوري الى القوات الامنيه الى
الجيش يتم تعيينهم من قبل المرشد الاعلى
بصفته وفقا الدستور الايراني القائد
القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه الايرانيه
الا ان الاحتجاجات الاخيره يبدو بانها همم
زعزعت ثقه المرشد في اشكري هذه ليست المره
الاولى التي همم
يقال بان اشتري يتم اقالته في نوفمبر
الماضي ايضا همم ترددت انباء باقاله
اشتري حينها قال المتحدث باسم الشرطه
الايرانيه بان الخبر غير صحيح واتهم
المعارضه الايرانيه ببث الاشاعات بهذا
الخصوص الا ان اليوم الخبر ياتي من وكاله
انباء بورنو وهي وكاله انباء تابعه لوزاره
الرياضه والشباب لدى الاحتمال وارد بان
يتم اقالته من منصبه بسبب فشله في ايقاف
الاحتجاجات طيب هو بالتاكيد مثل هذه
الاجراءات تضع المسؤولين الايرانيين في
حاله ضغط كبير على خلفيه هذه الاحتجاجات
لكن هل تعكس ايضا
في ادارتي هذه الازمه
بلا شك
التخبط لم ياتي فقط بسبب الفوضى داخل نظام
بلجاء بسبب
استمراريه الاحتجاجات بشكل غير مسبوق وغير
متوقع للنظام النظام لم يكن جاهزا
ليواجه احتجاجات تستمر اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر
تدخل شهرها الرابع وتنظل اليها فئات
مختلفه من الشعب وخاصه فئات الشباب
والنساء والجامعات الايرانيه ومختلف
القوميات الايرانيه من الاكراد الى البلوش
الى العرب الى الادبيين هذا التنوع في
ترتيبه المحتجين في الواقع الامر ايضا
دفعت النظام للمزيد من التخبط في التعطيل
والتعامل مع الاحتجاجات طيب يعني احتياج
ايضا وفي سياق الاخبار التي ورد لها قبل
الاخيره تحدثنا عن اضراب عن الطعام في
الايرانيه من عدد كبير من المحتجين
والمحتقلين خاصه من السجينات هل سيشكل ذلك
عامل ضغط اضافي على النظام امع العكس
تماما يعني سيبدو او يظهر انه غير مكترث
لي مثل هذه الانواع من الاحتجاج
في حاله التصويت الضوء على الاضراب عن
الطعام داخل السجون بلا شك سيكون له تاثير
همم ولكن عندما يتم اصدار القرار والضغط
على السجناء في همم في الغرف المظلمه ولا
احد يعرف عنها بهذه الحاله النظام يده
مفتوحه ولكن انعكاس هذه الاخبار من خلال
الاعلام الاعلام الدولي
والحديث عن ذلك باعتقاد له سيكون تاثير قد
لا يكون ذلك التاثير التي الذي تتوقعه
ولكن يخفف من شده الضغوط على السجناء
والسجينات بلا شك طيب هؤلاء السجناء سيدنا
مسعودنا بتعاطفهم دوري كبير خاصه من قبل
الغرب والبرلمان الاوروبيه على سبيل
المثال لكن هل يخدم ذلك قضيتهم ام يزيدها
تعقيدا
طبعا
المساله اصبحت معقده عندما يدخل الغرب في
دعم المحتجين ولكن لا اعتقد بان النظام
بامكانه ان يعمل الشيء بان النظام
الايراني يريد التفاوض مع الغرب يريد
التفاوض مع الغرب حول حول الملف النووي
وعندما يتفاوض حول الملف النووي يجب ان
يثبت للعالم بانه داخليا يحظى بالاستقرار
والثبات وامور من هذا القبيل لذا يحاول
النظام الايراني ان يعطي صوره ايجابيه عن
الوضع الداخلي لدى تاثير ياتي من هذا
المنطلق
نعم اذا من دبي كنت معنا الصحفي المتخصص
في شان الايراني مسعود الفجر شكرا جزيلا
لك
حظ البعوث الامريكيه الخاص بايران روبرت
مالي من اعدام اثنين من الموقوفين على
خلفيه الاحتجاجات مالي وفي تغريده على
تويتر قال انه يتعين على القياده
الايرانيه الاستماع لشبابها بدلا من قتلهم
مشيرا الى صدور احكام المواطنين
الايرانيين مهدي محمد ومحمد البالغين من
عمر 18 عاما و19 عاما في محاكمه وصفها
بالصوريه
قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بداوم
نتنياهو ان اسرائيل ستتصرف بحزم وقوه
الاجهاض التواضع الايراني العسكري في
سوريا
ان اسرائيل ستحارب بدونها ودهنيه ايران
تطويره رساله نوويه بطرق مختلفه وبشكل
مهني امام الراي العام العالمي
قال قاده عسكريون اخرى
الروسيه خففت من هجومها على مدينه باخ
مدمشق اوكرانيا وحولتها الناريه من حولت
قوتها الناريه الى مناطق المحيطه واشار
عسكريون اوكرانيون الى ان روسيا لم تعد
تهاجم مدينه الاستراتيجيه بالشراسه نفسها
التي كانت عليها شهر الماضي وتقوم بدلا من
ذلك بتغيير مواقع الدبابات والمدرعات
والمدفعيه باتجاه بلده سوليدار القريبه
حيث تسعى روسيا الى اختباء الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه
ان هذه الاشارات تعبر عن تخلي روسيا عن
هدف الاستيلاء على باخمه بالكامل
قال القائم باعمال رئيس جمهوريه دونياس
كالشعبي جادين السائين ان جميع الجنود
الذين اصيبوا في قصف مدينه من قبل القوات
الاوكانيه نقيل الى مناطق روسيه اخرى مع
ارتفاع عدد قتلى الجنود الروسي فيما كافكا
الى 89 جنديا وفق وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
كما اكلت الدفاع الروسيه ان الجيش الروسيه
دمر قاذ فتاه هيمارس التي استخدمتها القوه
الاوكرانيه لاستهداف الجنود فيما
من جهه الاخرى علينا الولايات المتحده لا
تاسفوا لمقتلي عاده كبير من العسكرين
نفذها الجيش الاوروبي ليله راس السنه
وقالوا المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
قال الصحفيين في البيت الابيض انه ليس
هناك اي تحسن من جانب الاداره الامريكيه
لان الاوكرانيين تعرض للغزو وهم يقاومون
ويدافعون عن انفسهم على حد قولهم
وسط الشائعات بان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين البالغ من العمر سبعين عاما يعاني
من حاله صحيه خارجه افاد رئيس جهاز
المخابرات العسكريه بان بوتين قد يكون
مصابا بالسرطان
طويله جدا اتوقع انه سيموت في القريب
العاجل وامنوا ذلك هذه الحرب يجب ان تنتهي
قبل ان يموت نعتقد ان بوت مصاب بالسرطان
لنا اعتقد انه مريض نحن نعلم انه مريض من
مصادر مقربه منه
افاد الشبكه دوسيه الى الامريكيه نقل عن
تقييم من الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه باحتواء
طائره مسيره ايرانيه سقطت في اوكرانيا
خريف الماضي على قطاعين على قطع صنعها اذا
13 شركه امريكيه و طبقا للتقييم المخابرات
فان من بين 52 مكونا استخرجها خبراء
اوكرانيا من الطائره المسير الايرانيه
طراز شاهد 136 كان 40 مكونا من صناعه
ثلاثه عشره شركه امريكيه واضافت تغيير انا
المكونات الاثنى عشر الاخرى تم تصنيعها
بواسطه شركات في كندا وسويسرا واليابان
وتايوان
البيت الابيض اذا الولايات المتحده تبحث
وسائل الاستهداف انتاج الطائرات المسير
الايرانيه من خلال فرض عقوبات وضوابط على
التصدير وتتواصل ايضا مع شركات خاصه
تستخدم بل تستخدم اجزاء من انتاجها في
تصنيع تلك الطائرات هذا هو فرضت الولايات
المتحده في السابق عقوبات على شركات
واشخاص اتهمتهم بانتاج او نقل طائرات مسير
ايرانيه تستخدمها روسيا لمهاجمه البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه في اوكرانيا
مشاهدينا ايضا مع استمرار الحرب في
اوكرانيا تعتمد روسيا كثيرا على الطائرات
الايرانيه المسيره خبراء قالوا انها تكلفه
اسقاط مسيره الواحده اكبر بسبع مرات من
تكلفه الاطلاق الامر الذي يستنزفك نتابعه
الحروب استراتيجيه وخططها تحدث فوارق مهمه
على الارض وان كانت من السماء في اوكرانيا
الامور لا تخرج عن هذه المعادله روسيا من
الجو تراه على ارهاق اوكرانيا في الارض من
خلال الطائرات بدون طيار المفخخه رخيصه
الثمن التي تجلوبها من ايران والتي تقوم
بتجميعها من عده مصادر
تدمير الاهداف الاوكرانيه الى استنزافيا
فكلفه اسقاط مسيره واحده تبلغ اكثر بسبع
مرات من اطلاقها
رغم ان مهاره الاوكرانيين تزداد في تدمير
المسيارات الا ان خبراء عسكريين يقولون ان
ذلك قد يكون لمصلحه موسكو على المدى
الطويل فالطائرات بدون طيار ذاتيه التدمير
يمكن ان تكلف ما لا يقل عن 20,000 دولار
لانتاجها في حين ان تكلفه اطلاق صاروخ ارض
جو يمكن ان تتراوح من 140.000 دولار
لصاروخ اس 300 من الحقبه السوفياتيه الى
500,000 دولار لصاروخ هايمارس
وفق التقديرات اطلقت روسيا نحو 600 طائره
مسيره منذ بدايه سبتمبر الماضي وبالغه
الارقام تحتاج اوكرانيا اموال طائله لصد
هذه الطائرات التي تكون اثارها التدميريه
تفادحه على اوكرانيا حاله وصولها الى
اهدافها
بلال الوجداني العربيه
ابلغ الرئيس الفرنسي ما بين المكرونه
باريس ستسلم كيف دبابات خفيفه وفقما اعلى
نقص الازياء واوضحت الرئاسه الفرنسيه في
بيان ان مكروه رغب بزياده المساعده
العسكريه المقدمه من خلال الموافقه على
تسليم هذا الدبابات خفيفه من طراز اي ام
اكس 10 ار سي مضيفه ان هذه المره الاولى
التي ستتزوج فيها القوات الاوكرانيه
بدبابات غربيه التصميم
مشاهدينا من باريس مراسل العربيه حسناء
هذه الدبابات الفرنسيه الى اوكرانيا يعد
تحولا في سياسه الدعم الفرنسيه لهذا البلد
ماذا في التفاصيل حسين حسين
نعم في الواقع احمد ركزت فرنسا خلال
الاشهر الاولى من الحرب في اوكرانيا على
ما كانت تسميه ما كان يسميه رئيسها تحديدا
ضروره عدم توفير اي جهد لايجاد حل
دبلوماسي تمثل ذلك من خلال اكثر من 20
اتصالا هاتفيا اجراها المكرون بن نظيره
الروسي حتى الحادي عشر من ايلول سبتمبر
الماضي عندما توقفت الاتصالات تماما بين
الرئيسين اتصل خلال هذه الفتره الرئيس
الفرنسيه حوالي 40 مره بنظيره الاوكراني
اخرها يوم امس عندما اكد له ان فرنسا
ستزود اوكرانيا بهذه الدبابات القتاليه
الخفيفه من طراز ان اكس 10 طبعا هذا البند
ياتي من ضمن بنود كانت عليها بند التزويد
بهذه الدبابات الخفيفه كانت اتفق عليه من
ضمني ما اتفق عليه خلال مؤتمر التضامن مع
الشعب الاوكراني الذي كان انعقد في باريس
في الثالث عشر من الشهر الماضي فرنسا اذا
عندما لم ينجح جهدها الدبلوماسي مع
توتنهام تحديدا تحولت نحو تعزيز مساعداتها
العسكريه لاوكرانيا من خلال انظمه دفاع
جوي وتعزيز نظام المدفعيه وكذلك تزويد
اوكرانيا بالذخيره وب- مضادات بمدافع
مضاده للاليات المصفحه وايضا بضروره
تمكينها من مواجهه المسيرات الايرانيه كما
تحدثت في مقدمه خبر احمد طه حسين ما زالت
الارقام ايضا تشير الان فرنسا تقبع في
مؤخره الدول الرئيسيه الداعمه لاوكرانيا
نتحدث هنا مثلا عن الولايات المتحده عن
بريطانيا
بالدعم التي تقدمه هذه الدول هل
ستسعى واشنط الاقوى والا عفوا باريس
مستقبلا لتوسيع دائره هذا الدعم وهل سيكون
ايضا اا دعما باسلحه اكثر نوعيه الى صحه
تعبير
عندما تسال فرنسا لماذا هي في مؤخره الدول
التي تساعد اوكرانيا عسكريه تجيب ان الامر
لا يقتصر على المساعدات العسكريه فرنسا
تساعد اوكرانيا في مجالات الصحه والمياه
والنقل والامدادات الغذائيه وعلى المستوى
الانساني وايضا تمكينها على المستوى
القضائي من عدم افلات المسؤولين عن جرائم
الحرب من العقاب من خلال دعمها امام
المحاكم الدوليه وتذكر بان المؤتمر الذي
كان انعقد في باريس خاصه المؤتمر الدولي
415 مليون يورو لقطاع الطاقه وثمانيه
وثلاثين مليون يورو لقطع الامدادات
الغذائيه وخاصه 25 مليون يورو لقطاع
المياه 22 مليون من لقطاع النقل و17 مليون
لاقطاع الصحه هذه كانت مقررات المؤتمر
الدولي ولكن بالفعل الولايات المتحده
عندما تكون قد قدمت مساعدات لاكرانيا
تقترب من مليارن من بينها 23 مليارا فقط
للمساعدات العسكريه فان المساعده الفرنسيه
الاجماليه في جميع القطاعات لاوكرانيا لا
تتجاوز حتى الان الملياري يورو من بينها
اقل من 800 مليون للقطاع العسكري مع اشاره
اخيره الى ان اوليكس رزني كاف وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني كان حدد حاجات بلاده خلال
استقباله نظيره الفرنسي سباستيانو الاسبوع
الماضي في كاف قال نحتاج اولا الى مواجهه
مسيرات الايرانيه والى تعزيز وسائل دفاعنا
الجوي والتعزيز نظام المدفعيه وهذا يحصل
بفضل المدافع سيزار الفرنسيه الثمانيه عشر
التي كانت قدمت مؤخرا وقال اننا نحتاج
ايضا للاليات المصفحه وفرنسا ستقدم
وهي كانت قد قام
للاليات المصفحه حسين
في خطاب التجمعات التي تشهدها المانيا ضمن
حملات الاحتجاجيه لافراد يطالبون بتغيير
سياسه الميلاد
بالدوله الروسيه او باقصى اليمن
موسكو داخل المانيا منذ بدء الحرب الدائره
في اوكرانيا الامر يتعلق بظبط سابق في
سلاح الجو الروسي وكان يطلق عليه في الاصل
الروت وغير اسمه الى ماكسلاند استقر في
المانيا قبل عقد من الزمن والثاني يدعى
ويتعهدوا بالولاء الاسلاميين الشرقي الذين
يدعمون حمله موسكو العسكريه في اوكرانيا
في حين يتخذ اخرون بعض الاسماء المستعاره
ولديهم علاقات غير معلنه مع روسيا
والكيانات الروسيه الخاضعه للعقوبه
الدوليه او بمنظمه اليمين المتطرف
وينشر بعض النشاط الموالينا لروسيا رسائل
الكريم لاين على الانترنت للجمهور الناطق
بالالمانيه تحليل رويترز وجد لقنوات
تليغرام باللغه الالمانيه مالا يقل عن 27
قناه تعيد باستمرار مشاركه الرسائل
المؤيده للكرملين الى جمهور مشترك يبلغ
نحو مليون و500,000 شخص بلال الوجداني
العربيه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد جديد
لدى الدوله والاقدام على خطوات اخرى على
صعيد الرئيس
في عده مناسبات مؤخرا
دعت القاهره مشاهدين خلال زياره رئيس
المخابرات المصريه الى الخرطوم عددا من
اطراف السودانيه الاجتماعيه في العاصمه
المصريه
لم يتحدث لكن الدعوه وجهت بالفعل لعدد من
القوى السياسيه السودانيه المؤثره للتشاور
بشكل منفصل واشار الذات المصادر الى ان
القاهره تنتظر ورقه سودانيه من القوه
الفاعله حول مطالبهم خلال الفتره المقبله
يلتقي رئيس مجلس النواب اللي بعطي لصالح
مع رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله خالد المصري
في العاصمه المصريه القاهره بدعوه من
اللجنه الوطنيه المصريه
وقانون الانتخابات كما يناقش الوضع
الحكوميه وتوحيد السلطه
من القاهره
متى ستبدا اعمال هذا الاجتماع
صباح الخير يا احمد بينما اتحدث اليك الان
الاجتماع على وشك
على وشك البدء او يمكن ان يكون قد بدا
بالفعل واهم ما سوف يناقشه بطبيعه الحال
هل هي
القواعد الحاكمه او القاعده الدستوريه
التي من الممكن ان تاهل الى انتخابات
تاخرت لاكثر من
54 اسبوعا همم لان كان موعدها كما تعلم في
ديسمبر 2021 همم بعض المصادر التي تحدثت
اليها القريبه من هذه المحادثات قالت انها
همم يعني همم جاءت بعد نوع من الضغوط همم
الدوليه والاقليميه همم لحث الاطراف على
التقدم في هذا الملف الشائك الذي اعاقه
العمليه السياسيه الليبيه برمتها وبينما
كنت اتحدث يعني استمع بالامس الى الدكتور
علي التكبالي البرلماني الليبي على شاشه
الحدث كان يقول بالحرف ان المجتمع الدولي
مل من عدم التقدم في الملف السياسي وربما
يكون لديه الحق الا ان هذا يتوافق مع ما
ذكرته للمصادر بشان الضغوط التي تقوم بها
كل من مصر وتركيا واطراف اقليميه اخرى
لدفع الاطراف نحو التوافق همم على هذا شان
وبالتالي ما يمكن ان ااه نستشف انه سوف
يطرح لانقاش هي القواعد الحاكمه للترشح
للرئاسه ومحاوله يعني همم
ايجاد جسر بين الطرفين للتوافق حول هذه
الماده ااه المجلس الاعلى الدوله كانت همم
طرح قبل ذلك ان تكون فتره همم او ان
يستقيل المرشح همم سواء المزدوج الجنسيه
او الذي يحمل الصفه العسكريه اللي فتره ما
بين سنه الى خمس سنوات قبل الترشح همم
وهذا طبعا يعني همم لا يتوافق معه وجهه
نظر الامان الليبي وبالتالي من الممكن ان
يكون هناك طرح مثلا تقبل اوراق الترشح
بعد تجاوز المرحله الاولى من الانتخابات
وقبل انتخابات الاعاده على سبيل المثال
تكون الاستقاله فهذا امر من الامور التي
سوف تناقش سواء بالنسبه لمن يحمل الصفه
العسكريه او لمزدوج الجنسيه في هذا شان
امر اخر همم حول همم قاعده الترشح للرئاسه
فيما يخص من هم همم يعني همم تتم مقضاتهم
الان امام القضاء الليبي همم ومساله
بطبيعه الحال ان في كل الدول يعني عاده لا
يتم الترشح لمن يصدر ضده حكم نهائي همم
مساله ان تكون اجراءات التقاضي مستمره همم
هذه المساله قد تعيق ترشح البعض وبالتالي
هذه من النقاط الاخرى التي يريد الطرفان
الشركه الهامه انت اشرت ايضا في سياق
حديثك الى الدور المصري والتركي في هذه
الازمه لكن في هذا الاجتماع تحديدا كيف
يمكن فهم طبيعه الدور المصري هل هو فقط
الى الصعاب وتهيئه الاجواء انها تملك
اوراق ضغط يمكن ان تدفع الطرفين للتوافق
اذا
بطبيعه الحال الطرف المصريه لا يشارك في
الاجتماعات ولكن بالامس علمنا ان اا اجتمع
بصوره منفصله مع الطرفين كلا اا على احدى
همم هذا القناع ياتي من قبل اللجنه
المصريه المعنيه بشان الليبي وهي همم لجنه
امنيه في مجملها همم تجتمع لتقريب واجهات
النظر ل- ل- لطرح بدائل همم عن المواقف
التي يتمسك بها الطرفان على سبيل المثال
من اجل التوصل الى نقطه في المنتصف من
الممكن البناء عليها للوصول على الاقل الى
اتفاق عام الى اتفاق يمكن البناء عليه
اعدا ذلك او يمكن ان يهيئ للبرلمان الليبي
على سبيل التحديد عن يقوم بسن القوانين
الخاصه بالانتخابات على هذا الاساس ولكن
هل تعرف المصريه لا يشارك في الاجتماعات
هو مجرد يقدم الممثلات اللازمه لكي يجتمع
طرفان في القاهره همم كما ذكرته من
القاهره كنت معنا مراسل العربيه
شكرا لك يا تامر
في تونس قال نقابيون في الاتحاد العام
للشغل ان المنظمه بصدد التشاور لاطلاق
مبادره لانقاذ تونس من الفوضى ازمه خانقه
في المنظمه بدا الاتحاد المشاورات مع هيئه
المحامين والرابطه التونسيه للدفاع عن
حقوق الانسان لانشاء المبادره هو ستقدم
منظمه النقابيه مقترحات وبدا الى الانقاذ
قضت محكمه تونسيه بسجن وزير البيئه الاسبق
مصطفى العربي 3 سنوات مع البراءه لسلفه
الشكر بالحسن في قضيه نفايات محظوره
مستورده بايطاليا هذا باضافه الى السجن
لمده 15 سنه في حق وكيل الشركه المورده
لتلك النفايات من ايطاليا الذي ما يزال
العربي
2020 مع عدد من المسؤولين في وزاره تحقيق
في القضيه
قال دبلوماسيون انه من المقرر ان يعقد
مجلس الامن الاجتماعي
في مجال الاغاثه الانسانيه الذي اتخذته
حكومه طالبان في افغانستان وكاله الامارات
واليابان عقد الاجتماع المغلق في الثالث
عشر من يناير
الجاريده على تويتر
قال متحدث باسم حركه طالبان ان ثمانيه
اشخاص قتلوا واعتقل سبعه بعد قارات على
معاقل تنظيم داعش افغانستان وشدد المتحدث
على تويتر ان لهؤلاء الاعضاء دورا رئيسيا
في الهجوم على الفندق في كابول الذي
يرتاده رجال اعمال
هذا وقد اعلن تنظيم داعش الشهر الماضي
مسؤوليته عن اغتيال مسؤول امني بارز في
طالبان في حادث باقليم باخشان في شمال
افغانستان
افرجت السلطات الاسرائيليه عن عميد الاسرى
الفلسطينيين كريم يونس بعد ان امضي 40
عاما في السجن يونس يعتبر بل يعتبر اقدم
سجين سياسيين في العالم بعمر يبلغ الان 66
عاما يذكر ان عائله يونس كانت تنتظر امام
سجن هدارهم ولكن تبين بعد اتصال بان مصلحه
السجون وضعت يونس في احد شوارع مدينه
وسطها اسرائيل
طالبه الدول العربيه والاسلاميه مجلس
الامن الدولي بان يصدر خلال اجتماعه
المقرر اليوم حول القضيه الفلسطينيه ادانه
صريحه للزياره التي قام بها وزير
الاسرائيليه الى باحه المسجد الاقصى
بالقدس الشرقيه المحتله واثار التمديدا
واسعا وقال المندوب الفلسطيني هذا الامم
المتحده في رياض منصور من المجتمع الدوليه
يريد ضمانه بان الوضع الراهن الاماكن
المقدسه بالقدس سيحترم بالافعال وليس
بالاقوال
ده انترناشونال كيمياتي هاست سبيك ويذون
فويس على المجتمع الدولي ان يتحدث بصوت
واحد لرفض هذا التطرف ورفض هؤلاء
الارهابيين وتلك العناصر الفاشيه في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ولن نكتفي بالبيانات
الجميله التي ستطلق في مجلس الامن نريد ان
يتم تنفيذها بطريقه ملموسه نريد ان يتكرر
هذا السلوك على المسجد الاقصى والحرم
الشريف ونريد ضمانه لاحترام الوضع
التاريخي القائم بالافعال وليس بالكلمات
فقط هذه هي الرساله كما يقولون الصوره
تتحدث بصوت اعلى بكثير من 1000 كلمه
مشاهدينا او فيها بعض الفاصل
في اطار تقليص القوه العامله امازون تعتزم
الغاء 18 الف وضيفه
وفي نشاطنا ايضا
قرصنه شملت حسابات سياسيين تسريب لبيانات
البريد الالكتروني ل 235 مليون حساب تويتر
في سابقه منذ قرن بسبب خلافات بين
الاغلبيه الجمهوريه ولم يتمكن المرشح
الاقوى
الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب الذي سيطر عليه
الجمهوريون بعد الانتخابات النصفيه في
نوفمبر
في سابقه تسجل منذ قرن فشل الجمهوريون في
اختيار رئيسا لمجلس النواب الامريكي خلال
عده جلسات رغم فوزهم في الانتخابات
النصفيه في نوفمبر الماضي
هو بحسب راي العلاقه الشخصيه السيئه بينهم
كارت في السابق والان هو فقط موعد الحساب
اثبتت حاله الفوضى التي يعيشها الحزب
الجمهوري واضعف شخصيه الرئيس بغض النظر عن
النتيجه التي سيتم التوصل اليها عكس
الواقع الذي فرضته المراه الحديديه نانسي
الاول
من جميع الاطراف وهذا سيكون خيارا صعبا
للغايه
مع غياب لاي منافس جاد لمكارسي عكس
اليومين الاولين لسيطره الحزب الجمهوري
على المجلس الصعوبات التي تواجه اغلبيتهم
متحده في مواجهه الرئيس جودا الامر الذي
سيتيح هامشا من المناورات الديمقراطيين
الذين يتوجسون من بدء منافسهم تحقيقات
تنال من الرئيس وافراد عائلته بانتظار
صفقات قد تسمح لهم بالحصول على ما فشلوا
بالحصول عليه في الانتخابات النصفيه
[تصفيق]
اللفت بكل ما يحصل حتى اللحظه تبقى مطالبه
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب بدعميما كارتي
التي لم تلقى اي استجابه لدى نواب تجمع
الحريه الامر الذي يطرح المزيد من علامات
الاستفهام حول تاثير ترامب على الحزب
الجمهوري في هذه المرحله ريتا سليمان
العربيه واشنطن
[موسيقى]
ومن القاهره
السياسيه
اكثر الجمهوريين تشاؤما لم يكن يتوقع ان
تصل حاله الانقسام بين تيارات الحزب الى
هذه المرحله هل كان ذلك مفاجاه لك متوقع
ليس مفاجاه بطبيعه الحال طرح اسما مع كرسي
لم يكن يحظى بالقبول في البدايه وانما
اعيد تدوير اسمه انت تعلم انه خاض
انتخابات 2000 ايضا 2015 كان زعيم اقليه
تاريخ الرجل معروف لكن المجموعه التي
تعترض عليه مرتبطه بامرين الامر الاول ان
الجمهوريين الان في مرحله عدم الاستقرار
لا علاقه لها فقط بالرئيس السابق ترامب
لكن تداعيات او ارتدادات ما يعرف به
انتخابات التجديد النصفي للكونج ثاني نحن
هنا نتحدث عن معركه قادمه ليست فقط متعلقه
بانتخابه رئيس مجلس النواب هناك اشكاليه
بطبيعه الحال متعلقه بما هو قادم انا في
تقدير القضيه ليست اجيولوجيه الرجل الرجل
معلوم في الساحه السياسيه وكان زعيم اقليه
وله حضوره لكنه ال- ال- الامور الان تحتاج
الى صقر من صقور الحزب الجمهوري الحزب
الجمهوري لديه كلا حقيقيه الان هو اعاده
لما الشمل بعد الانتخابات التجديد النصفي
وايضا الاستعداد لمعركه الانتخابات
الرئاسه الرجل يحتل كما تعلم موقع متقدم
بعد الرئيس ونائبه في افقي الصلاحيات
الفيدراليه المعلومه في النظام الفيدرالي
الامريكي وبالتالي هو له همم اهميه كبيره
والقضيه ليست في الفشل في هو ربما سنكون
امام احد سيناريوهين سيناريو هو طبعا انه
يجتاز هذه المعركه ويصبح رئيس مجلس النواب
لكن ستكون هناك مشكلات اكبر متعلقه باداره
المشهد داخل الكونجرس في هذا التوقيت هناك
يعني جمله من التشريعات التي يجب ان يتم
تمريرها وما جرى في تمرير الموازنه خلال
ايام الاخيره لن يكون هو وحده المرشح انك
تشريعات كثيره الفيدراليه من المفترض ان
يتم توافق بها فالمعركه ستبدا بعد انتخاب
وليس الان بالنسبه للبديل حتى سيكون
المصري بعيد عن ثقينا عليه لان الليبيين
او اقصى اليمين ال- ال- ال- ال- الموالي
لترامب اثبت قوته همم اذا كنت تتفق معي في
هذه الجزئيه
يعني بالتقدير طبعا هناك اتفق مع حضرتك
لكن المشكله الان في انه الحسبه الجمهوري
اصبح يمين يمين ويمين وسط فهناك تيارات
صاعده لم تعد تقتصر فقد على التيار اليمني
المباشر او اللي احنا بنسميه التيار اكثر
يمين بالنسبه للحزبه وهؤلاء طبعا مواليين
بطبيعه الحال ايه الرئيس ترامب لكن الحزب
الجمهوري بالمناسبه هو ليس ترامب والواقع
يقول غير هذا هناك يعني استعدادات لعدد
كبير من المرشحين الخريطه تتسع بالمناسبه
حضرتك وهناك خلال الاشهر المقبله اسماء
سترشح وبالتالي الرئيس ترامب ليس هو وحده
لا سيكون في المواجهه وربما ستكون هناك
علامه استفهام حول همم
المعركه ستكون معركه من داخل الكونجرس
ومرتبطا به اداره المشهد باستمرار هذا
الوضع يعني انا مجلس النواب معطل
والكونجرس ايضا سيكون غير فعال في هذه
الحاله هل يستفيدوا الديمقراطيون من هذا
الوضع
بالتاكيد يعني لكن لم نصل الى موضوع الشلل
التشريعي او ما الى ذلك هذا تحويل كبير
طبعا لكن هناك هتبقى مشكله في اداره
المشهد داخل الكونجرس المستفيد الاول
والاخير والرابع الحقيقي هو الرئيس جو
بايدل لانه بطبيعه الحال سيسوق او سيؤكد
على فشل الجمهوريين في لم الشمل او اداره
المشهد من الداخل وكما تعلم الديمقراطيين
من الذكاء انهم سيستمروا هذا اذا استمر
الامر بطبيعه الحال
هيكون الرابح هو جو بايد لكن اعتقد انه
الديمقراطين سيدير معركه اخرى هدفها تاكيد
عدم وجود شعبيه ليه الاسماء الصاعده حتى
منافسه حاكم جوردن هو غير يعني مرضي عنه
بالصوره الشامله ربما ستصعد اسماء اخرى
ليس لها تاريخ كبير لانه كما اشرت انه ما
كانش فاضي انتخابات 2015 ولم ينجح والقضيه
ليست في اديولوجيا او العقيدي نحاكم ليه
لانه اراه معلومه للجميع وعلاقته بترامب
ربما تبقى يعني عليه شكرا جزيلا لك
الجماعه على من القاهره دكتور طارق فهمي
استاذ يعلم السياسييه تحيه سيد طارق
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه الفقره نقوم
فيها بجوله على تداولات اسواق المنطقه
اليوم ابرز خبر نتابعه هو استمرار تسجيل
المستويات المتدنيه على الجنيه المصري
لاحظوا يوم امس حصل ديفالي وايشن على
الجنيه كما كان متوقعا بالفعل بالسوق لانه
نحن قبل فتره شاهدنا ارتفاع اسعار الفائده
بمصر بثلاثه بالمئه وبالتالي كان السوق
يترقب متى سيليها عمليه تعويم جديده
للجنيه ايضا في ظل تكدس البضائع بالموانئ
والمشكله تحد الدولار فبالتالي اتت الخطوه
يوم امس ويبدو انها مستمره اليوم الدولار
عم بسجل سجل باعلى سعر 26 فاصل 69 لاحظوا
الان يتداول عن 26 فاصل 65 من بعد ما فقد
الجنيه او ارتفع الدولار على الجنيه سبعه
بالمئه يوم امس بجلسه يوم امس اليوم يواصل
تسجيل المكاسب على الجميع المزيد حول هذا
الموضوع ضمن برنامج الاسواق العربيه بعد
قليل عاد ذلك هذا اداء السوق المصريه
بالوقت الجنيه عم ينخفض هذا بيجعل قيمه
الاصول اقل السوق المصريه مرتفعه في ظل
عمليات شراء على سوق لاجاءه سيرتي عند
مستوى قياسي يرتفع باثنين بالمائه ماذا عن
باقي اسواق المنطقه همم لنلقي نظره صباحا
كانت كلها على ارتفاع في ظل اجواء ايجابيه
بالاسواق العالميه وارتداد على اسعار
النفط الان دبي وابو ظبي على بعض تراجع
سوق الاسهم السعوديه يفقد باليومين يعني
اليوم ويوم امس فقد المكاسب اللي كان
سجلها باولى جلسات هذا العام اتراجع الان
بثلاث ارباع نقطه المئويه بالكويت عندنا
بعض الارتفاع او قطر الارتفاع جيد باذن
اثنين بالمئه نظرا سريعه على الاسهم فاذن
بالسعوديه منذ مطلع السنه اصبحنا بالسالب
20 من النقطه المئويه السوق مرتفعه على
يزال من مستويات 10,033 بدي ديسمبر ارتفاع
حوالي اكثر من 500 نقطه بعض الاسهم اللي
عليها اخبار لانها تركي وماريا شركه
استشارات للاندماج مع الدرع العربي امام
حس طلعت على رخصه تنقيب اللي الذهب والزنك
من وزاره الصناعه جاهز عند بدء العمل
بالكويت بدا من اليوم والسحابه على شركه
بستين مليون ريال ريتال عملت اتفاقيه
تطوير مع ل- اا تطوير مجمع ترفيهي سوق دبي
على تراجع بنصف نقطه مئويه بالوقت الحاضر
اعمار على تراجع اعمار العقاريه واعمار
للتطوير بينما سالك على ارتفاع دبي
الاسلامي ايضا على همم تراجع سوق ابوظبي
كذلك على تراجع باكثر هذا الامارات دبي
الوطني اصدار سندات بعائد 45% مدتها ثلاثه
سنوات ساكتفي بهذا القدر لان هذه الفقره
قصيره المزيد من كل اخبارنا ضمن الاسواق
العربيه بعد قليل العوده اليك
شكرا نادين اذا مشاهدينا ارتفاع كبير في
اسعار الاجهزه الكهربائيه او السلع في مصر
بسبب الازمات الاقتصاديه العالميه والتي
اصابت الاسواق بالركود مع انخفاض لسعر صرف
الجنيه المصري مقابل الدولار وصلت ترقق
بين الارتفاع جديد في الاسعار خلال الايام
المقبله
بترفع كذا مره في الشهر
في الاستعداد للزواج لشراء الاجهزه
الكهربائيه
ليفاجئ في كل مره بزياده الاسعار
الاجهزه الكهربائيه انا مش هاقدر اكملها
ان هي وصلت رفعت 25 و30%
ازمه تكورون ومتلاها من الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه اثرت على الجنيه المصري الذي
تم تعويذه لمرتين في العام الماضي لينخفض
للمره الثالثه الان في البنوك امام
الدولار ليفقد الجنيه المصري اكثر من 60%
من قيمته منذ مارس الماضي الامر الذي ادى
للدفاع غير مسبوق في كافه الاسعار
المنتجات متوفره بس الاسعار عاليه الارز
عالي وسكر عالي
كل حاجه غليت الواحد هيجيب حاجات محدوده
للسلع واعلان رئيس الوزراء محاوله ضبط
الاسعار والزام التجار بوضع اسعار السلع
الا انا مجلس النواب شنب كبيرا على وزير
التموين بسب عدم احكام الرقابه وارتفاع
اسعار السلع
يعني رغيف الفول ورغيف الطعميه النهارده
وصل خمسه جنيه سته جنيه لو اسره بسيطه
بتفطر الصبح من الاسر الفقيره عاوزاها 70
80 جنيه عشان تفطر بس فول وطعميه
انخفاض سعر الجنيه مقابل الدولار قد يشكل
امام الاستثمارات والسياحه والتصدير
الايجابيات طبعا
الاقتصاد المصري او السوق المصري هيكون
سوق جاذب بشكل كبير للهوتماني وايضا
السناديق السياديه الخارجيه والعربيه
لدخول لاقتناعس الفرص الاستثماريه في بعض
الشركات
السلع كل ذلك يشكل الان اولويه عمل
الحكومه والمواطن على حد سواء في ظل
ارتفاع الاسعار وتوقعاته بزيادات قادمه مع
تخفيض قيمه الجنيه راندا ابو العزم
العربيه القاهره
قال صحيفه واشنطن فاصله خبراء في امن
المعلومات رصده تسريب بيانات البريد
الالكتروني المرتبطه بنحو 235 مليون حساب
في تويتر وذكرت صحيفه ان هناك مخاوف
حقيقيه من مقايضه هذه البيانات وان تشكل
تحديدا لاعتقال المعارضين السياسيين او
الذين يستخدمون تويتر لانتقاد اداء
حكوماتهم واشارته واشنط واصل ان القراصنه
قد يستخدمون عناوين البريد الالكتروني
للتحكم في حسابات تويتر
الصحيفه الان البيانات التي يتم تسيبها من
حسابه تويتر قد تغير نتائج الانتخابات
وتلحق المزيد من الضرر بالخصوصيه
من تسريبات تويتر الى ازمه التسريح
العماله في امازون حيث على رئيس التنفيذي
لامازون دوت كوم اند جيسي في مذكره
الموظفين ان تخفيضات الوظائف في الشركه
ستطالب اكثر من 18 الف وظيفه في اطار
تقليص للقوى العامله وبدات الشركه التي
تتخذ من سياسه المقرئ لها تسريحه الموظفين
بقسم الاجهزه في نوفمبر الماضي وتستهدف
امازون تخفيض عشره الاف وظيفه بهذا القسم
فضلا عن قسمين الموارد البشريه والتجزئه
شركه امازون التي تعد ثاني اكبر ارباب
العمل بالقطاع الخاص في الولايات المتحده
تواضفوا اكثر من مليون و500,000 شخص
وتتاهبوا لنمو محتمل بوتيره ابطا
هذا مشاهدينا فيما يجبر تضخم المرتفع
الشركات والمستهلكين على خفض الانفاق
المدير العام الاتحاد الدولي للنقل الجوي
انتقد وضع قيود على سفر الصينيين وقارئ ان
هذه تدابير اثبتت عدم فعاليتها سابقا في
وقت اعاده هذه الاجراءات الى الذاكره ما
اشار اليه خبراء في وقت سابق ان العالم
اصبح اكثر خبره في التعامل مع هكذا
اهديدات بعد الجائحه متابعه
[تصفيق]
الشوارع الخاليه
المكاتب الهجينه المطارات المقيده
سيناريوهات تعيد الى الاذهان ذكريات لم
يتجاوزها كثيرون حتى الان والعالم لن
يتحمل مثيلاتها مره اخرى حسب خبراء
تدابير لا يريد الكثير من الناس التفكير
بها ولكن الاجراءات التي فرضتها بعض دول
العالم على القادمين من الصين اخيرا
قعدتها الى الواجهه الصين بدورها هددت
بتدابير مضاد
لكننا نعتقد ان قيود الدخول التي فرضتها
بعض الدول على الصين تفتقر الى الاساس
العلميه
لاتحاد الدولي للنقل الى التعليم
همم
ان هذه الاجراءات مجرد احتياطات لحمايه
المواطنين وهي مبنيه على قواعد الصحه
العامه واتخذت بعد استشارات مع خبراء من
عده دول اجراءات اختبرها العالم
لثلاث سنوات مضت بين ان الانظمه الصحيه
والاقتصاديه تعلمت من هذه التجارب واصبحت
اكثر خبره في التعامل مع هذه الانواع من
الازمات وفق ما يرى خبراء الصحه والاقتصاد
وتتحدث عنه الدراسات التي اجريت بعد ان
ضربت الجائحه انظمه واقتصادات الدول في
مقتل
في الاخبار الرياضيه المشاهدين اهتم
الاعلام الدولي بشكل غير مسبوق بحفل تقديم
النجم البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو لاعبا
جديدا لنادي النصر السعودي على ارضيه ملعب
مرصود بارك بالعاصمه السعوديه الرياض فيما
يلي مشاهدينا نستعد ابرز عناوين الصحف
والمواق العالميه التي تحدثت عن هذا
الموضوع
[موسيقى]
وفي ختام هذه الساعه الاخباريه مشاهدينا
نذكر بابرز العناوين
16 محتاج الايرانيه تحت التعذيب في مراكز
الاحتجاز وسجينات يضربنا عن الطعام
قاده عسكريون اوكرانيون يرجحون تخلي القوه
الروسيه عن هدف الاستيلاء
برعايه الامميه صالح والمشيه يلتقيان
بالقاهره للتوافق حول الانتخابات الليبيه
في امان الله مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]